[Music]
okay and of course it's a great honor to
be here so I'm gonna talk about you know
what scientists do looking trying to
understand or physicists and astronomers
trying to understand the basic laws of
nature and surprisingly science takes
all kinds of twists and turns
surprisingly string theory has entered
this problem in a fundamental way and
I'll end with some discussion of the
frontiers so the search - everybody
wants to know why and how the world
around us
works and this search has been going on
for many centuries and the most
interesting part of it to me anyway is
there's things that we understand very
well there's things that we can't hope
to understand and then there's those
things that are right at the edge that
we might be able to understand but we're
if we are careful and we choose
correctly but might not so you know as
you've been hearing at this festival
there is just an incredible amount that
we know about the world around us that
was unimaginable centuries ago we know
how you know the cookies they gave me in
the green room are giving me energy to
move around up here
yet there are incredibly simple
questions that a three-year-old can ask
how did the universe begin what's inside
a black hole how does the universe end
that we don't we don't have an answer to
so how do we answer these questions well
there are many different approaches and
all approaches are needed
but one that has played an important
role is a contradiction so a famous
example of this
it comes from Einstein who wondered what
would happen if he held a mirror in
front of his face and started running at
the speed of light would the image
disappear or not
and he used Maxwell's theory and got one
answer he used Newton Galileo theory and
got another one so this was a
contradiction in the laws of physics and
it was in a contradiction in the basic
laws of physics that were known at the
time and in order to resolve this
contradiction he came up with a
absolutely spectacular insight which has
of course been verified in great
experimental detail that in fact nothing
can ever travel faster than the speed of
light thereby avoiding this
contradiction and this completely
reorganized our view of space and time
in order to make sense of this we have
to have space and time be part of one
space-time continuum
one can turn into the other and so it
led to a complete change in the way that
we view the universe and in fact if you
look at all the great advances in
physics every one of them had behind
them some contradiction of of this type
for example quantum mechanics was born
out of a contradiction between the laws
of thermodynamics that had been studied
in the nineteenth century and the laws
of electromagnetism you needed a quantum
for the electromagnetic field not to
explode and that led to quantum
mechanics and in 1925 and
so on continuing until today and what I
want to emphasize is that physicists and
astronomers are now in the best position
imaginable in the 20th century there
were two there are two kind of pillars
of 20th century physics Einstein's
theory of general relativity and quantum
mechanics and wonderfully it's not a bad
thing it's a wonderful thing
wonderfully they're incompatible as
we'll discuss and almost certainly
putting these together will lead us to
some very important new insights about
the nature of the physical world on the
same scale as the insights that were
brought about by quantum mechanics and
relativity so that of course is
incredibly exciting the scale for this
though is not the scale of a National
Science Foundation grant three years the
scale is decades or centuries it was a
century from Schwartz shields discovery
of the black hole till chef Seurat last
month
that's how long these things how long
these things take
so let me just say a few words about
what general relativity and quantum
mechanics are so Einstein taught us in
his general theory of relativity that
the force of a gravity is an illusion
that what actually happens is it the
presence of a mass like the Sun or like
chefs black hole curves the space-time
around it and something which wants to
go in a straight line actually moves at
each point it's following its nose and
going forward but in the end the whole
arc ends up being
a closed orbit and this Earth orbit
around the Sun is just like the orbit of
light around a black hole that Shep and
the event horizon team just took a
picture of now in quantum mechanics the
basic idea is the uncertainty principle
another thing that we have believed to
be true until the beginning of the 20th
century is that there was an absolute
notion of position that that had
complete infinite precise meaning in
quantum mechanics we learn that that's
not true
anything which is moving must also have
some uncertainty in its position which
in general in the in the real world is
very small but when you get down to
atomic objects it can become very large
now nothing is immune from the
uncertainty principle so when you put
the uncertainty principle together with
Einstein's theory of general relativity
you really get in a lot of trouble
because what you learn is that space and
time themselves are uncertain and if you
don't know what that those words meet
neither do i or anybody else on earth
we're trying to figure it out and it's a
grand wonderful exciting challenge to
try to figure this out and we feel that
we're making some progress now those
were words the fact that quantum
mechanics and general relativity don't
fit together has several aspects it was
first noticed by Poli in the 50s there's
a machine for which called quantum field
theory
for putting together classical theories
with quantum theories coming out with
something consistent this has worked for
the weak the strong and the
electromagnetic interactions last time I
counted there were 43 Nobel Prizes that
had been given for this over the 20th
century it's been tested to 16 decimal
places it's the most accurate history in
the his most accurate theory in the
history of human thought it must be
correct
but when you apply it to gravity you get
you get garbage ok so you have to do
something about that
now there's one attachment that we know
of that gives something sensible but we
don't know if it's the attachment the
nature ordered or not nevertheless it's
been interesting to think about so the
laws of physics that we know are not
self consistent we have to figure that
this out this is something which is at
the edge of our knowledge understanding
how Einstein theory of general
relativity and the uncertainty principle
can fit together and it's a very
concrete and well posed problem and it
turns out that black holes somehow as
well as in astronomy in this line of
theoretical reasoning black holes have
come to play a central role and so what
is a black hole well if you're on the
earth the escape velocity is 11
kilometers per second you have to jump
at 11 kilometers per second if you could
do that roaring air friction you could
just keep going forever
escape the gravitational field of the
earth and go on out to outer space on
the moon it's only two kilometers per
second there isn't as much mass in the
moon and if you have enough mass in one
place you would have to go faster than
the speed of light
Einstein told us that's impossible so
nothing can get out of a region in which
there is above some critical
concentration of mass energy such
regions
it seems fantastic people were reluctant
to believe that such regions really
exist I think chef in the event horizon
telescope have vanquished the last
holdouts
now we've really seen them and that's
called of course a black hole that's
what a black hole is now black holes
were discovered by Schwarzschild in a
really in equivocal way by solving the
Einstein equations in 1915 but nobody
understood what they were there was 50
years of argument about what this
solution meant and the great man
Einstein himself this is a direct quote
from one of his papers in 1939 said that
they didn't exist if he were said this
in my general relativity class I
wouldn't be able to give him a passing
grade that is not to say I'm Stein
wasn't a very very very smart man it's
just that it is really really really
confusing and it took 50 years of many
of the great minds of the 20th century
to figure out what a black hole is
what's a horizon
how do you understand things that orbit
around it how do you make them what is
their behavior and that problem was
eventually solved for many years people
didn't believe they exist
we had incremental evidence astronomical
evidence that they existed which got
better and better and now it's all out
there and in plain view and so now we
know they exist
but they're rather strange objects what
we find the way that we finally
understood them is that they are nothing
and when I say nothing I really mean
nothing
not what as in this room where there's
air or outer space where there's no air
there's a sense in which a black hole is
the edge of space there isn't even
anything inside it and moreover they are
featureless they're the simplest objects
in the universe
it's not like a star where if you have
two stars of the same size and
brightness
they still differ in myriad different
details at different compositions
molecules moving around in different
ways and and so on every star is
different in many many ways but black
holes are purported to be rather
different all black holes of the same
mass and spin are supposed to be exactly
the same and John Wheeler who also
invented the word black hole
characterized this by saying that black
holes have no hair so hair is a feature
on an object some as longers on the
shorter you could cut it you can comb it
different ways something on the outside
of our heads and and that's
there's nothing outside on the outside
of a black hole that can distinguish it
this is rather curious that the universe
should contain subject such objects such
very simple pure fundamental objects now
just when we thought we'd finally
understood what a black hole was Stephen
Hawking threw a monkey wrench into the
words and the way he did this was by
saying well you know the world is
described by quantum mechanics not
classical mechanics Einstein's equations
from classical equations there's no
uncertainty principle in the equations
that Schwarz hilde solved and the
uncertainty principle has no exceptions
everything must be subject to the
uncertainty principle it would be
mathematically and consistent to have
some objects get a pass that they don't
have to obey the uncertainty principle
and that includes black holes and what
Stephen Hawking found is that the
horizon one way of describing it though
of course they're precise equations one
way of describing it is that the horizon
itself is subject to some uncertainty in
its position and that enables things
which were inside to at a very slow rate
to kind of slip out and so in fact black
holes according to Hawking are not
completely black they radiate at a
temperature and here's the formula for
the temperature which a very important
formula in modern physics and
now inscribed on his stone and
Westminster Abbey so black holes aren't
black they radiate due to quantum
mechanical effects now they obey a law
the so called law of thermodynamics
which tells you how hot the radiation is
as a function of the mass of the black
hole now in the 19th century the people
had measured the behavior of many
different kinds of systems water oil
carbon gases and they measured how their
temperature would change as you change
change the pressure or the volume that
they're in or put it on a burner
measured the properties of their
materials and one of the really stunning
beautiful advances in science in the
19th century was Boltzmann's discovery
that the law the so-called laws of
thermodynamics follow from the what was
then a hypothetical theory that matter
is composed of individual molecules and
then you can use statistical reasoning
to derive the laws of thermodynamics
which becomes secondary laws and so if
you know Boltzmann explained to us that
if you know how the temperature depends
on the mass you know how much structure
there is inside of something you know
how many molecules there are and how
many different ways they can move so in
a manner following Boltzmann Hawking's
formula was used it's on the beckon
signed Hawking formulas bekenstein was
also involved in these developments
so we have a formula for how many
gigabytes how much stuff there is in a
black hole and it's proportional to the
area of the black hole and there is an
important factor of four Newton's
constant which measures the strength of
gravity and Planck's constant which
measures the strength of quantum
mechanics so this is a very striking
Universal formula which ties together
many different branches of physics
gravity quantum statistical mechanics
and thermodynamics general relativity
very mysterious formula and we don't
understand in all we know that it must
be correct
Hawking gave arguments that consistency
argument that this must hold but we
don't really understand why it's true
now before I get on to that I want to
say that this is a huge number all that
data in the Google data banks would fit
inside a tiny black hole a trillionth of
a trillionth of a millimeter and in fact
we have reason to believe that this is a
fundamental bound that it is a law of
nature that there's a maximum on how
much information you can cram into a
region of a given size you can derive
contradictions if you had something
which would violate this bound and so we
think that in fact that black holes are
the best storage information devices in
the physical universe and this is going
to be trouble for Moore's law because
Moore's law says that if you have a chip
of a given size every few years you can
double the amount of information that
you can put on that chip but if you put
the numbers in
you find that after 300 years your chips
will become black holes okay now if
you've been paying attention
I've told you two things which seemed
completely at odds with one another and
one is that a black hole is the simplest
object in the world characterized by
wheelers phrase a black hole has no hair
the other is that according to Hawking
they're the most complex objects in the
world and so how is it that these
opposite descriptions of black holes can
be consistent this is a huge paradox for
physics and one that sat there for many
decades and then we got some insight
into it from string theory
now string theory we don't know if
string theory describes the real world
or not but we do have I would say as
overwhelming evidence that it describes
some universe some mathematical system
which at least lives in the mind which
is self-consistent and contains both
quantum mechanics and general relativity
and it's a world whether or not it's our
own in which we have a fantastic amount
of control over the equations and we can
ask the question how does string theory
resolve this paradox string theory is a
theory which purportedly unifies quantum
mechanics and general relativity it must
find some solution to this paradox and
if it doesn't it's dead
and so we investigated this problem and
we found that indeed there was a mess
with in string theory of counting all
the gigabytes that are in certain kind
of black hole and it exactly agreed
including the factor of four and in many
more details that I can't describe with
all the predictions that Hawking made so
we had one context in which this puzzle
had a complete has a complete resolution
and I should mention that that an
important ingredient in this argument is
something called conformal symmetry it's
a special symmetry that black holes some
black holes have which enable us to do
the calculation now when we did the
calculation it was a long difficult
calculation which took many pages use
did a lot of detailed properties of
string theory and some branch of
mathematics called algebraic geometry
and it all seemed a very special
situation occurring in string theory but
as time went on we learned that the
details of string theory were not really
essential that we could develop more and
more simplified arguments and the
simplified arguments really only
depended on this conformal symmetry and
in fact conformal symmetry is present in
some black holes which are very rapidly
spinning and so we can sort of throw out
the string theory but keep the trick
that string theory uses to reconcile the
maximally simple and the maximally
Complex pictures of black holes with one
another and this works for very rapidly
spinning black holes we
know what the spin of the black hole is
but we are there are a number that have
been observed that have this very rapid
spin and we are in so here's a picture
of a black hole this is more like GRS
1915 one in our own galaxy fed by a
nearby companion star and mater bleeds
off circles around the black hole and
the symmetry the Jets coming out of the
poles of the black hole the black hole
is sitting there and the symmetry acts
in this little region here which is the
horizon of the black hole and that is
where all the gigabytes are stored okay
so we have these theoretical reasonings
and these pictures of how we might
resolve this contradiction between
quantum mechanics and general relativity
but we're physicists and we'd like to
connect it in however remote a fashion
with things that are being observed and
in particular we'd like to know what the
consequences are of this conformal
symmetry which will be present if m87
turns out to be rapidly spinning and
there is a suggestion that m87 couldn't
be rapidly spinning because rapidly
spinning black holes often have long
Jets like m87 does and i want to say
that it's a wonderful and hit really
truly historic development that after a
hundred years of thinking about black
holes that just in the last month we've
seen one and it brings all of these
investigations it gives them a further
sense of reality
so here well here's pictures of Shep's
array here is a picture of m87 which
they were trying to image and here's
what they actually saw
and so in discussion with the event
horizon team we're now looking at what
would how would we see in this donut and
in more more highly pixelated versions
which will appear in the future how will
we test for this conformal symmetry and
there's more data to be released and
this is something we're very excitedly
working on here's a prediction which
we've published about the polarization
profile the data would will be out in
the next year which would be a signal of
this conformal symmetry which is the key
to reconciling the puzzle raised by
Hawking now not all black holes have
spent and the puzzle is there for all
black holes this spin and the conformal
symmetry is a tool that we used and we'd
like to understand all black holes and
there have been some very recent
interesting developments on this so I
told you about how black holes have no
hair in fact they have a very subtle
form of hair and this has been
understood in the last few years by
Stephen Hawking Malcolm Perry and myself
and there been many other follow-up
papers on it and I don't have enough
time to go into a detail but I just want
to say it all follows from a careful
application of Einstein's
once principal so the equivalence
principle says that if you have you're
in an elevator elevator with rocket Jets
on the bottom in outer space that is the
same there's no difference between that
and what you mean by saying there's no
difference turns out to be a very subtle
thing but the simplest approximation to
that is that there's no experiment that
you could do in the elevator
if the elevator isn't too big between an
elevator with rocket Jets in outer space
or an elevator on the surface of the
earth feeling the force not from the
acceleration but the force from the
Earth's gravitational pull
Einstein told assists were equal now
imagine a series of elevators tiling the
surface of the black hole and we want to
describe the black hole by an array of
elevators and all the measurements in
them including the synchronization of
their clocks and it turns out that
understanding when two such
configurations are equivalent is more
subtle than previously thought and in
fact there are subtle differences that
can be ascertained by subtle
observations of this type and that will
would give that imparts what we call
soft hair hair the word comes from
wheeler and the word soft is a word
which in physics is used to mean
something with very little energy that's
hard to detect and so that is being
pursued as a way to understand all black
holes which must have some solution of
the problem of quantum mechanics and
general relativity
and finally let me conclude a a sense of
frustration that scientists feel and
trying to talk about this because some
of the things are so specialized I feel
a little bit like somebody who went out
and discovered the the Grand Canyon and
the beautiful rock formations and so on
and then came back and was trying to
describe it well now we've got one
picture but from Jeff but trying to
describe it just in words without any
photos it's hard the equations are
incredibly beautiful but it takes a long
time to learn them and this was the best
I could do in an hour in conclusion the
road to increase our understanding to
move a little bit beyond the edge of our
current knowledge is full of surprises
it never goes the way we think it's
going to go we start out to try to
understand one thing and we learn about
something else and but it's full of
twists and turns but we don't know where
it's going but pretty clear we're going
forward thank you
you
you
[Music]